you may have heard the news that Marvel
Studios as President Kevin Feige is
going to be developing a Star Wars movie
with Kathleen Kennedy for Lucasfilm and
Disney Studios this comes as a bit of a
surprise since Marvel has a lot on their
plate right now including phase four
phase 5 the Disney Plus shows that are
coming to the MCU and the sony disney
deal for spider-man how's it going
everybody it's Warren and although this
really probably won't affect the MCU too
much as Kevin Feige is a true
professional and extremely good at what
he does it does offer a little more
insight into the Sony Disney Marvel deal
for spider-man and it gives us some
insights in a way that you probably
wouldn't expect but it does reveal a lot
about Sony so let's break down what this
means for the deal but first I am super
excited to announce that I am officially
sponsored by G fuel G fuel is an
insanely good tasting drink that gives
you energy without the crash if you
already drink it or would like to try it
you can use the code cosmic @ G fuel
comm to get a 30% discount and of course
if you'd like a chance to win an Xbox
one or a ps4 be sure to subscribe to my
channel and leave a like and a comment
on the video so originally when the Sony
and Disney deal for spider-man fell
through the CEO of Sony came out and
released a public statement and in that
public statement the CEO said that Kevin
Feige the president of Marvel Studios
was too busy to focus on spider-man if
he didn't own more of him now in a way
this kind of made sense Kevin Feige has
phase four phase 5 the Disney Plus shows
all coming up and a ton of new
characters including the x-men the
Fantastic Four and characters like
Doctor Doom and Galactus are heading to
the MCU as well so he has a lot on his
plate but spider-man is an insanely
important character to the MCU and Kevin
Feige fought really really hard to be
able to use him in the MCU in the first
place so that statement never really
made too much sense yes Marvel wanted to
own more of spider-man because a lot of
his success was widely due to him being
a part of the MCU and being a part of
Avengers infinity war and Avengers
endgame but there have been a lot of
reports going back and forth since the
start of this deal and with so many
reports it's really hard to tell what is
real and what is simply a busy
this tactic because you have to remember
yes we are a fandom and Sony definitely
hears our voices but at the end of the
day they're a business and they're gonna
use whatever tactics they can to come
out on top and it seems like one of
their tactics was to say that Kevin
Feige was too busy to focus on
spider-man just to make people upset
because as we can see that is not the
case not only is Kevin Feige going to
tackle phase four phase five the Disney
Plus shows all of the new characters
coming to the MCU but now he is also
going to tackle making a Star Wars movie
for Lucas Films and Disney Studios not
to mention they have a company retreat
coming up where they're going to talk
about the future of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so I think it's pretty clear
that Kevin Feige can take on a lot and
not only can't he'd take on a lot but he
can do it extremely well just look at
the success of Avengers in game so it
seems like Sony just said this as a
business tactic because clearly Kevin
Feige has time to take on spider-man in
fact spider-man is probably top priority
for him right now
spider-man was supposed to go on in the
future of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
to lead the Avengers he's an extremely
important character to the MCU so
there's no way that Kevin Feige does not
have time to take care of spider-man but
unfortunately like I said this is a
business deal and they're going to use
business tactics to try to get what they
want but again clearly Kevin Feige is
not too busy to take care of spider-man
but let me know what you think about
this I know there are some people that
would prefer spider-man to remain at
Sony and I know there are a lot of
people that would really love for
spider-man to stay in the MCU and go on
to lead the Avengers let me know what
you would like to have happen let me
know your thoughts in the comments and
again don't forget to use code cosmic at
G feel calm and don't forget to
subscribe to my channel and leave a like
on this video so you can enter my Xbox
one and ps4 giveaway as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof